my name is Laura and I'm looking to
teach club Spinney first thing I learned
and you need to know about those
fittings that there are three separate
grips one is a pump grip you hold the
club near the knob between the webbing
between your thumb and index finger
there's also the claw grip as in holding
the club like a claw so coin rip and
with pointer if you hold the clubs
between the index and middle fingers if
that's the way you like to avoid some
people like between the middle and ring
fingers what I really like to teach is
hybrids hybrids make my brain work fun
thank goodness here's what I know about
hybrids hybrids are combination of any
two types of motion there are several
ways you can move through hybrids you
can move in extensions you can move in
isolations you can move in anti-spin
extensions also
you can move into flowers or anti step
flowers you can move with sinks one hand
doing a snake while the other does
another motion the cloves can also
translate which is holding a fixed
position while moving through space so
if this Bob is doing a flower while the
other ones translating it might look
something like that like boy the hands
and the clubs can be moving in four
separate timings and directions
there's slit saying together saying
together opposite and split up while the
hands are holding the clubs and moving
through these positions
the clothes to be doing all sorts of
things the folks would be moving in any
any one of those four timing and
direction of themselves my hands are
moving in together saying and then
suddenly move into opposite opposite you
get this sort of effect now at any one
of these four points up down left right
you can switch which type of indirection
is going on with the hands same holds
true for the clothes my hands are still
in split opposite the club's however our
movie in split opposite stuff still
confusing to me at which of any of these
four points you have options the puck
can either be toward the body away from
the body you can have both clubs away
one pub away one club board for both
clubs toward ends are split opposite can
reverse that I'm going to try an
anti-skid extension up with one hand and
an extension with the opposite hand here
I'm going to switch which one soon
as you can at any point what you want to
remember is that these reference points
are crucial to creating a smooth clean
style which you want to end up doing is
referencing down-left both straight up
right and make those as clean as
possible when moving through the motions
and learning
it's in position you can make another
hybrid instead of rotating with the club
bits doing an anti spin extension I'm
going to isolate the opposite direction
the clubs come pointing straight at each
other and then out to the other side
here's another one this club is going to
do an anti spin extension while this
club moves in isolation I used four
segments up left down right to connect
all these hybrids together so at any one
of these four angles you can switch from
100 to it up
I can either be here here or here at any
one of these four here here here here
here here here here let's play
that's why I love penguins here's what I
know about hybrids hybrids make my brain
work fun that's why I love my notes
that's why I love my notes
that's why I love my notes thank
goodness
you